Oui, je sais, il y a déjà dix mille vidéos sur Youtube qui parlent de l'alcool
En même temps maintenant tu prends n'importe quel mot du dictionnaire
Essuie-glace
Tu le tapes sur Youtube
Et tu trouves forcément des dizaines de vidéos sur ce sujet
Enzo sur le Net: les essuie-glaces
Les podcasts de Matéo : les cinq types d'essuie-glaces, remix dubstep
Déjà, je me dois de rappeler que l'alcool est à consommer avec modération
Une règle que tout le monde respecte, évidemment..
FAUX
J'ai l'impression que, avant de boire
bah t'es un mec normal
Quand tu dis que tu fais du cheval, tu fais aussi double poney ou que cheval ?
Et puis en buvant quelques verres d'alcool,
bah t'es remplacé par un autre toi
Un toi plus désinhibé
HEY! J'te remplace
Wahooo
T'as des origines tahitiennes toi
Comment tu sais ?
J'connais les femmes
Jusqu'à un moment donné où t'arrives à un verre
Qui s'appelle le verre de trop
Excuse-moi, SERVEUR!
Un verre de trop s'teuplait
Un verre de trop ? Okaaay un p'tit verre de trop pour le monsieur
Merci mon grand
La particularité de ce verre,
c'est que le mec stylé en toi
est remplacé par un autre mec
Qui est une sorte de...
De grosse merde
Allez viens chez moi on va faire des bisous
Hé s'teuplait
Oui, moi aussi je me suis déjà bourré la gueule dix mille fois
Mais je suis désolé
Boire ça rend quand même un peu con
j'veux dire
Quand t'as une idée bourré, c'est rarement une idée de génie
Oh putain j'suis défoncé
Hé j'ai une idée
Flash spécial exceptionnel
Yohan, un jeune bourré de 25 ans, ivre mort
trouve le remède contre le cancer
Nan ça se passe rarement comme ça
Un mec qui a une idée bourré, c'est plutôt
Hé les mecs j'ai une idée j'vais tondre le iench'
Des barres
En même temps je comprends que les gens aient peur de l'alcool
Quand je vois les reportages qu'ils font à la télé
Alors certes l'alcool c'est hyper dangereux
Il faut faire très attention et je suis le premier à le dire
Mais dans ces reportages, ils arrivent à faire passer des jeunes qui passent une soirée plutôt normale
pour des put*** de toxicomanes
Paris, 11ème arrondissement
Il est 23 heures
Romain et ses amis semblent passer à peu près normale,
pourtant sur la table, que des alcools forts
L'ambition est claire, s'alcooliser
Là en général, ils emploient des expressions en anglais que personne n'utilise dans le monde
Toute la nuit, ces jeunes vont pratiquer le binchdrinking
Le speeddrinking
Le whiskijumping
Ou encore l'aquaplanning
Non c'est juste une petite soirée entre potes
On boit pour le délire
Le délire, c'est comme ça que Corentin minimise son acte d'alcool défonce
Non mais voilà on n'abuse pas trop
On prend quelques verres juste pour le kiff
Le kiff, c'est bel et bien le mot qu'il emploie pour désigner cette drogue
Il faut arrêter avec vos questions vous me saoulez là
Saouler, le mot choisi semble être un lapsus révélateur
Excusez moi elles sont où les toilettes ?
Toilettes, c'est sans doute le lieu où ce jeune homme ira se faire vomir
Après s'être pris une biture express
Mais non j'ai juste envie de démouler un cake
Cake, c'est sans doute le mot que ce jeune emploie...
Ces reportages préventifs c'est vrai que c'est vraiment une bonne initiative
Mais ils prennent vraiment des cas incroyables
Les jeunes qu'ils interviewent dedans
C'est pas forcément des lumières
L'histoire c'est qu'on boit pas comme des abrutis
On boit, on a fini notre verre
On en boit un autre
D'accord
Bon ben c'est ce qui s'appelle boire comme un abruti en fait
Moi j'ai déjà fait dix milliards de soirées alcoolisées
Mais j'ai jamais vu un mec faire ça
Beaucoup ne savent plus ce qu'ils font
Certains se mettent en danger
Euh lui c'est pas juste un mec bourré,
c'est un mec bourré serial killer
*Musique de films d'horreur*
Moi j'aime pas trop boire
En plus quand je bois j'ai des mauvais réflexes
Bon comme le réflexe de rappeler mon ex
Par exemple
Faudrait inventer un système pour empêcher ça
Appelle Julie
Désolé vous êtes actuellement bourré
Même moi rien que tu m'as soufflé dessus je suis un peu rébou
*bruits de téléphone*
*pleurs et cris de tristesse*
Quand tu bois de l'alcool, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une sorte de filtre
Qui se dépose sur tes yeux et qui change le monde
Salut
*cris de douleur* Je suis tombé
Ah yes j'ai plus rien
(Baissez le son pour votre bien)
*Bruits dégoûtants*
Non ça marche pas
J'ai pas arrêté de le répéter dans la vidéo mais  vraiment buvez avec modération
C'est vraiment très sérieux le moins possible voire pas du tout
Ou éventuellement un petit panaché à votre mariage
Merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo
Si vous avez aimé n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce en l'air
À partager ma vidéo, à vous abonner à ma chaîne Youtube
À vous faire un sandwich
À très vite je vous aime tous
Vraiment tous tous tous
Hein il y a pas de soucis tous heu tous
*chuchotte* venez voir mon spectacle Norman sur scène
Actuellement à Paris au Palace
Je sais pas pourquoi je chuchote c'est un délire
Allez au revoir